getting shanked to death by a secret
klingon sleeper agent being cloned into
existence just so you can die after
giving up your brain tissue dying's
never been easy and it's even worse on a
starship here are the most devastating
deaths in the star trek franchise
in the classic 1967 star trek episode
the city on the edge of forever the
enterprise visits a deserted world where
they discover an ancient portal into the
past a sick dr mccoy passes through it
and changes history so that the
enterprise never existed forcing kirk
and spock to follow him through the
portal to fix the timeline finding
themselves in the great depression the
duo's search for mccoy leads them to a
woman named edith keeler who runs a
homeless shelter
i
find her most uncommon mr spock
while spock tries to discover the event
that caused history to be altered kirk
gets to know keillor and the two start
falling in love when spock learns that
in order to fix the timeline they must
restore a history where edith keeler
died in a fateful car accident kirk is
determined to continue his relationship
with her though in the end it's kirk who
stops mccoy from saving her devastated
the captain is forced to sacrifice the
woman he loves to save all of humanity a
powerful ending to what is often
considered the best star trek episode
ever star trek ii the wrath of khan is
considered a classic for many reasons
including its brilliant villain its
dramatic climax and of course the death
of mr spock after the release of star
trek the motion picture in 1979 actor
leonard nimoy made it clear to producers
that he wasn't enthusiastic about
returning to play spock again but they
were able to get him back thanks to a
terrific script wrath of con director
nicholas meyer said producer harp
bennett lured him with the promise of a
terrific death scene which shatner and
he played so touchingly in the film the
enterprise's engine is damaged while
locked in combat with khan's stolen
starfleet ship the uss reliant spock
heads down to the reactor room to fix
the problem but to do so he must endure
a lethal dose of radiation his sacrifice
saves the ship and he delivers a final
emotional speech to captain kirk that
has gone down as one of the most iconic
in film history
thankfully nimoy had a change of heart
during principal photography which led
to reshoots setting up his return in the
follow-up film but at the time his death
was a first for trekkies who were forced
like the helpless captain kirk to watch
a beloved and iconic character die
before their eyes introduced in the star
trek the next generation second season
episode the emissary the half human half
klingon klar was a special federation
emissary brought on board the enterprise
during a crisis involving a derelict
klingon ship a former lover of klingon
security chief lieutenant wharf the pair
rekindled their physical relationship
during the mission worf is left jilted
however when kaylar refuses to commit to
him in a klingon bonding ritual in the
fourth season episode reunion kailar
returns when the klingon chancellor kim
pek is on his deathbed and she doesn't
come alone with her is alexander her son
sired by wharf but after kaylar gets too
close to uncovering the treachery of the
villainous klingon duros she winds up on
the wrong side of his blade with her
dying breath kailar leaves alexander in
worf's care dwarf gets his revenge on
doros but khaylar's death marked a major
turning point in his story forever
defining his character it gave him a son
and alexander who would go on to play a
substantial supporting role in the
series
though not a major character the young
bajjorn officer encincito jaxa made an
impression on audiences with her
wide-eyed optimism and soulful
personality her first appearance came in
the fifth season of star trek the next
generation where she was caught up in a
cover-up at starfleet academy over the
death of a fellow cadet she would make a
surprise return in season seven where
she was assigned to the enterprise and
up for a promotion the episode revolves
almost entirely around the lives of four
young officers aboard the enterprise
during their crew evaluations but when a
cardassian double agent arrives looking
for safe passage back home jaxa is
recruited by captain picard to help
pretending to be a bjorn prisoner she
will make his trip more believable with
him posing as a returning bounty hunter
however at the climax of the episode the
plan to return jaxa to the enterprise
fails and the young officer is killed by
a cardassian patrol it's a grim dark
ending to what was otherwise a
relatively lighthearted episode and a
devastating end to what was a promising
new character the first feature film
starring the cast of star trek the next
generation was designed to be a passing
of the baton from the original star trek
crew kirk scotty and chekhov all
appeared at the beginning of the film to
christen the enterprise bee the first
enterprise with a new crew but during
their first voyage disaster strikes won
a strange space anomaly called the nexus
damages the ship taking kirk with it
what if i told you
i found a new truth
the nexus
nearly 100 years later captain picard
and the uss enterprise d are facing a
villain named sorin who is seeking to
enter the nexus himself and threatens to
destroy a planet to do it when picard is
drawn into the anomaly he finds none
other than his predecessor captain kirk
as he was when he was taken a century
earlier the two enterprise captains work
together to stop soren but kirk is
killed during the film's climax much to
the dismay of the fans while not the
most well-regarded star trek movie
receiving plenty of criticism from
audiences and critics alike it's hard to
deny the devastating impact kirk's
passing had on the fandom killing off
the man who was arguably the biggest
star in star trek stunned audiences and
it was regretted almost instantly by
actor william shatner who seemingly made
it his personal mission to return to the
role making her debut in the fourth
season of star trek deep space nine
torah zeal is the half bajoran half
cardassian daughter of the series main
villain gul ducat the product of an
affair while ducat was the prefect of
beijor zeal and her mother were sent to
a neutral planet after the cardassian
occupation came to an end but their
transport ship the ravanak was lost
after an attack by the breen years later
evidence of the ravanak's crash site
surfaces so major kira and ducat mount a
rescue mission and discover zeal alive
fearing her existence might threaten his
power in the cardassian military ducat
plans to kill zeal but is talked out of
it by kira eventually zeal forges a new
relationship with her father and comes
to live aboard the deep space nine
station she forms a sisterly bond with
kira and even a romantic relationship
with the enigmatic former spy garrick
but when the imperialistic forces of the
dominion take over the station zeal
defies her father by helping the
resistance fight back during the
climactic moments when starfleet retakes
the station ducat can't convince seyal
to leave in a shocking final twist his
top lieutenant demar murders zeal in
cold blood like sito jaxa zia was an
upbeat optimistic character whose
presence added a warmth and earnestness
to the series not only did her death
devastate audiences it sent ducat into a
psychotic spiral ultimately breaking him
following the sixth season of star trek
deep space nine series mainstay terry
farrell who played the science officer
jadzia dax was up for contract renewal
according to farrell she was told by
producers to accept whatever offer she
was given because if she wasn't on deep
space nine she would be quote working at
kmart understandably frustrated farrell
declined their offer however rather than
writing dax out of the series in a way
that could allow for future guest
appearances the producers opted to kill
the character off in a devastating
season finale most viewers unaware of
the behind the scenes drama were taken
by surprise when a possessed ducat
murders dax while she visits a bajorn
shrine dax had recently married
long-time fan favorite worf and the pair
were hoping for a baby the exit of one
of the series biggest characters in the
midst of such an emotional story was a
brutal heartbreaker for fans who is this
person how did she get the symbiant do i
even want another dax in my life does
she always talk this much
these are all very good questions
thanks to the magic of science fiction
of course the trill symbiont within her
was given a new body and actress nicole
deboer replaced farrell as the new
character esri though not exactly a
death per se the series finale of deep
space nine did see the end of corporeal
existence for the show's longtime
captain benjamin cisco having finally
accepted his role as the emissary of the
prophets cisco battles against their
greatest enemies the parades meanwhile
ducat has been cast out by his own
people and embraces the paw rates as a
way of getting revenge on his nemesis in
a final showdown in the bajorn fire
caves cisco and ducat have it out once
and for all though cisco and the
prophets prevail the captain's physical
body is destroyed while the crew of deep
space nine the bajorn people and his
wife and son all mourn his death it's
revealed that cisco actually transcended
his physical existence he is now a
prophet himself it was the first time in
star trek history that a series ended
with the death of a major character
though actor avery brooks hasn't
performed on screen in over 20 years
cisco is technically still out there
somewhere and could theoretically return
the death of chief engineer charles
tripp tucker in the final enterprise
episode is considered crushing by many
trekkies but another death of sorts can
be seen as much more devastating the
season 3 episode similitude saw tripp
critically injured and the ship's
resident doctor cooks up an unusual cure
to save him using the genome of a rare
species of larva they create a clone of
trip so they can harvest its brain
tissue to save the original given that
the new being will only have a lifespan
of about two weeks the plan is to let
the clone live out its life and die
naturally thereby allaying most of their
ethical concerns but their convictions
are tested when the clone grows from a
child to an adult in a matter of days
and begins to form friendships with the
people aboard the enterprise the clone
of trip falls in love with tapal and
becomes a valued member of the crew
eventually sim as he becomes known is
forced to confront the nature of his
existence while everyone around him must
wrestle with the emotional consequences
of their actions though a short-lived
clone instead of a main character the
death of sim was still heartbreaking and
possessed the emotional weight lacking
from tripp's actual death the star trek
franchise was rebooted in 2009 by jj
abrams and became the same fast-paced
roller coaster that had made the
director famous but if there's one thing
abrams loves more than lens flares it's
tugging at an audience's heartstrings
with devastating emotional moments star
trek begins aboard the federation
starship uss kelvin as it encounters a
mysterious spatial anomaly when an
enormous romulan starship emerges from
it and kills his captain the first
officer george kirk played by then
unknown chris hemsworth takes command he
attempts to fight off the enemy ship but
the battle goes badly kirk orders all
hands to abandon ship including his wife
going into labor in sickbay having lost
their autopilot he stays behind to pilot
the kelvin setting a collision course
with the romulan vessel to save the
fleeing crew the last man on the bridge
kirk calls his wife aboard a shuttle and
delivers an emotional goodbye the
husband and wife named their son james
tiberius kirk just as the two ships
collide despite only knowing the elder
kirk for a matter of moments his death
is a devastating gut punch for audiences
to start the film this next entry on our
list is the death of an already deceased
character as the entire first season of
star trek picard had the former
enterprise captain mourning the loss of
his old friend commander data who had
been killed in an act of self-sacrifice
in the 2002 film star trek nemesis if
you had data's neural net perfecting a
flesh and blood host body would be
relatively simple but his neurons died
with him
thanks again to the magic of science
fiction data makes a return in the
picard series though when data
surprisingly asks picard to end his life
to give his existence meaning the latter
agrees the two share a quiet moment and
data sips a glass of wine before laying
down and passing away it's perhaps one
of the most emotionally heart-rending
deaths in the franchise while data had
technically died once before this more
conclusive ending is far more
devastating we're losing him again after
a nearly 20-year absence
a holdover from star trek voyager the
character each ebb made a surprise
appearance in a flashback during the
star trek picard episode stardust city
rag but the ex-borg's return was
short-lived as it was revealed that it
was his death that motivated seven of
nine's vendetta against the ruthless
criminal businesswoman bejazel icheb was
found aboard a damaged borg vessel with
several other borg children they were
eventually taken aboard the voyager and
disconnected from the collective just
like seven of nine though the other
children were returned to their people
ichab's parents had bred him as a living
weapon against the borg he would thus
remain on voyager returned with them to
earth and later joined starfleet but in
stardust city rag we're shown his grisly
end ichab is abducted and ripped apart
by bejazel so she could harvest his
parts to sell after his demise 7 would
never be the same and neither would
audiences with many feeling that icheb's
graphic death scene had gone too far
star trek discovery the first star trek
series in more than a decade was a new
beginning for the franchise it set
itself apart in a number of ways from
its predecessors from its darker tone to
its big budget action commander paul
stamets and chief medical officer hugh
culber played by anthony rapp and wilson
cruz respectively were the first gay
crew members in star trek history living
together on the ship as a committed
couple that's why it came as such a
shock when in the first season cobra was
brutally murdered after crewmate ash
tyler determines he's suffering from
some kind of traumatic repressed memory
he goes to culber for help the chief
medical officer discovers that tyler
isn't human at all and has been
surgically implanted with a starfleet
officer's personality on top of his real
identity that of a vicious klingon
messiah voke who promptly breaks
culber's neck while some critics knocked
the death of cobra as an example of the
unfortunate trope of killing off gay
characters it's hard to argue that it
was anything less than one of the
season's most devastating moments star
trek discovery brought colbert back in
season two and he's since followed the
crew of discovery into the 32nd century
where he and stamets remain a happy
couple
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
star trek are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you